if you can think and speak and write you
are absolutely
deadly
nothing can get in your way
[Music]
the best thing you can do is teach
people to write because there's no
difference between that and thinking and
one of the things that just blows me
away about universities is that
no one ever tells students why they
should write something it's like well
you have to do this assignment
well why are you writing well you need
the grade it's like no
you need to learn to think
because thinking makes you act
effectively in the world thinking makes
you win the battles you undertake and
those could be battles for good things
if you can think and speak and write you
are absolutely
deadly
nothing can get in your way
so that's why you learn to write it's
like
and i can't believe that people aren't
just told that it's it's it's like
it's the most powerful weapon you could
possibly provide someone with and i mean
i know lots of people who've been
staggeringly successful and watched them
throughout my life i mean those people
you don't want to have an argument with
them they'll just slash you into pieces
and they're not in a malevolent way it's
like if you're going to make your point
and they're going to make their point
you better have your points
organized because otherwise you're going
to look
like and be an absolute idiot you are
not going to get anywhere
and if you can formulate your arguments
coherently and make a presentation if
you can speak to people if you can lay
out a proposal god people give you money
they give you opportunities you have
influence
that's what you're at university for so
that's what you do teach people to be
articulate
because that's the most dangerous thing
you can possibly be
so and that's motivating if people know
that it's like well why are you learning
to write because you're here's your
sword here's your m16 right here's your
bulletproof vest
like you learn how to use them
it's an endless mystery to me why
that isn't made self-evident
so that's the sort of thing that can
drive you mad trying to sort out
it's like people are there's a there's a
conspiracy to bring people into the
education system to make them weaker
so
i guess that keeps the competition down
maybe that's one way of thinking about
it
if your students are stupid they're not
going to challenge you
[Music]